rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning relief nation it's even my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing gift you have
inside to you that needs to be shared
with the world so let's start the day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sit on today's message be
prepared to be misunderstood
over to you Mark Zuckerberg it's really
good to be idealistic but be prepared to
be misunderstood anyone working on a big
vision is gonna get called crazy even if
you end up right anyone taking on a
complex problem is gonna get blamed for
not fully understanding it even though
it's impossible to know everything up
front anyone taking initiative will
always get criticized for moving too
fast because there's always someone who
wants to slow you down
in our society we often don't take on
big things because we're so afraid of
making mistakes that we ignore all the
things wrong today if we do nothing the
reality is anything we do today is gonna
have some issues in the future but that
can't stop us from getting started so
what are we waiting for it is time for
our generation defining great works how
about stopping climate change before we
destroy the planet and getting millions
of people involved manufacturing and
installing solar panels how about curing
all diseases and getting people involved
by asking volunteers to share their
health data track their health data and
share their genomes you know today our
society spends more than 50 times as
much treating people who are sick as we
invest in finding cures so people get
sick in the first place it makes no
sense we can fix this how about
modernizing democracy so everyone can
vote online
and how about personalizing education so
everyone can learn these achievements
are all within our reach let's do them
all in a way that gives everyone in our
society a role
let's do big things not just to create
progress but to create purpose taking on
any big project means that you're gonna
have a healthy dose of fear it's just
going to happen you're taking on
something big and you have to be kind of
afraid of it if there's no fear it means
your goal is so tiny so small so like
already checked off in your head that
it's a it's a crappy goal your goal
should inspire you should motivate you
shouldn't power you and that also means
you're afraid like all the greatest
things in your life will come on the
opposite side of fear the big things
that you want to do in your life will
come as a result of crashing through
some fear that you had conquering it and
doing something that you thought was
impossible or beyond your capabilities
and then what often happens is we set
these big goals for ourselves and then
we're afraid to take action because we
don't want to feel the fear because we
feel like the fear is holding us back
and we don't want that uncomfortableness
in our lives and so how do you get the
courage to bust through that fear how do
you get the courage to I don't think you
can just say don't feel the fear I think
the fear is there I think the fear is
real I think when you want to do
something big you want to call that
customer you want to pitch that plan you
want to start this new business is its
fear the fear is real I think at least
my solution is giving myself an even
bigger fear so that it forces me to
drive into action so I make a huge fear
so much bigger than the actual fear that
I'm feeling to go in the opposite
direction so I do that through regret if
I'm going to start a business as an
example when I started this new business
there's a lot of fears a lot of what-ifs
there's a lot of worry there's a lot of
what if this doesn't happened what did
that happen what if I lose this buppa
buppa buppa buppa what I look at is okay
this is my Jeff Bezos idea you know I'm
200 years old looking back in my life
saying what if I don't do this what if I
don't take action the biggest things
that you regret or not usually the
things that you do but the things that
you say no to things that you're too
afraid to do that's usually when you're
on your death
what you regret the most now I'm trying
to minimize Rehberg Rhett's as I go
through life so I imagine a situation
starting this business doing this thing
I'm afraid of if I don't do it for the
next hundred and sixty years I'm gonna
regret this I'm gonna have this anchor
weighing me down and I just compound
that back to today like 160 years of
pain and regret and what-ifs I don't
want that I just got to know I can deal
with it not working out that's a
short-term pain but I don't want decades
of uncertainty and regret and so I make
that future pain brought back to today
so big that it forces me to take action
I just make that future pain and fear
bigger than my current pain and fear of
doing that thing that I need to do and
so I found that that's the best way that
I know how to break through the fear I
found like when they said don't be
afraid don't be afraid don't be afraid
it didn't work because I still had to
deal with that fear but by giving myself
a bigger fear it helped crush that
little fear and I hope you can apply
something like that to your business to
your our missions to your aspirations
because people will misunderstand you
the bigger your dream is the more people
will not understand it and they'll hate
on it and tell you why it's not gonna
work out and some of that will seep in
to you and you'll say they're right like
this thing is kind of crazy this is kind
of too big and you start holding
yourself back you start small talking
yourself to become your own little man
you get lost in the present moment and
if you can keep perspective and think
you know what I'm okay with this thing
I'm working out I'm okay with failing
I'm okay with losing what I invested
into this I'm okay with that
not going anywhere but I'm not okay with
what I'm never okay with is not knowing
I have to know I gotta know I want to
put everything that I've got to give it
my best shot so I can look back and say
I gave you my best shot and it didn't
work that's okay but not that you know
like even I gave it one more week they
give it one more month if I made one
more phone call or admit what's one more
event
maybe maybe we could've work that's
gonna eat you up for the rest of your
life don't let that happen so the
question today today is I'm curious what
is one big fear that you have inside you
that is preventing you from doing the
thing that you know that you want to do
what is that fear write in the comments
below release it release it as you write
in the comments release it from you it's
in the public now it's out there release
it so you can go and do that thing that
you really want to do so you don't live
a life full of regret I also want to
give a quick shout-out to Sonya Wallis
Sonya thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word it really
really really means a lot to me and I
hope you enjoyed so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you and I hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events best
you got to get some haters you need
haters no school is gonna teach you how
to get a hater okay high school
elementary school colleges what do they
teach you want to be the most popular
person now you want haters okay the
companies that are hated are the
companies that are exploding the people
that are hated are the people that
explode if I don't hate you if nobody
hates you nobody knows you so the reason
I'll tweet for instance when we started
we had this that newsletter that I sent
out okay we send it out every week we
were hitting people
once a month and we started getting
complaints you send stuff out too much
my office came to me we went to twice a
month they came to me we have more
people pulling off of the newsletter
good double up again why I want haters
okay so we start sending out one every
week and then I started Twitter account
I actually had people write grant
cardone
social media people grant cardone is an
example of what not to do with social
media
I said freaking just multiply just
increase it okay we were doing like four
tweets a day good do to an hour why
because I want my competition hating my
guts someone I'm talking about me I mean
I don't really want hate people to hate
me you understand what I'm saying about
I want them so so energized that they
actually start pushing me they start
promoting me we live in the airbrushed
era
yeah people augment themselves and have
you had any pressure as anybody talked
to you about you know we want to change
your hair we want to do this to you or
no no no never I think that's because
like in England a science an indie label
and it's not really about that kind of
thing you know they don't really feel
like a major that much and then when I
did science a major record company in
the rest of America of Columbia I was
you know I was already quite established
in in England as in not known for
putting my foot down and not letting
anyone be like
face and so now I haven't and also like
I'm not going to knock this because like
look more people know me live people
like you know like want to be rude about
it I'm gonna be fat and stuff like that
then like that's kind of makes me not
want to change even more do I mean
because because I just start giving in
and also I don't know these people like
being all but about me I mean I never
gonna meet them they were anonymous on
YouTube no I don't care it's only my
mind's eye paper raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
we believe that people with passion and
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me I don't ever give
up I'd have to be dead or absolutely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
most a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details